Brett wrote in what normal childhood
activity becomes uncool or odd when you
reach a certain age how about running
right when I was a kid with my cousins
in Argentina hey let's run sure but you
just run everywhere wherever you're
going you run you've a lot of pent-up
energy a lot of pensive energy if now I
were to when I'm just I don't know
walking to the subway stop run at full
speed with my work my lunch bag and
stuff that would start to be odd you
would look like you were incredibly late
for something and if you had to speak to
someone and they ask you why you're
running late or something yeah and you
said no I'm just doing this for fun that
would be very strange do you have any
others of what is considered uncool I
mean like a lot of people talk about how
you really adults shouldn't really play
video games I don't have a problem with
the adults playing video games and I
think it's an unfair one because video
games as we know them now we're not
something that prior generations of
adults grew up with so just because
adults didn't use to play video games I
don't think is a good reason to suggest
that there's something kind of odd about
current adults playing video yeah I
don't think video games are any
different than you know sitting for a
couple hours and watching television
reality shows or what have you if it's
just something you do in moderation for
entertainment that's totally fine yeah I
mean my mind goes to maybe like high
school age where kids maybe start
smoking pot or getting involved in drugs
or drinking and at the time you know in
some circles that's considered the cool
thing to do but you know if you're doing
it to excess when you get older it's
like what are you doing with your life
looking like a deadbeat a little yeah
and the high school one and even younger
there's a point at which when you make
fun of other kids you're sort of seen as
the dominant and powerful and it's sort
of like something to be respected and
thought of as a really great thing like
wow this is really this person is
running the show here very quickly and
it's sad that it doesn't happen earlier
but certainly once you get to college by
and large and in the adult world when
you're regularly making fun of other
people whether it's even behind their
back or in front of them it transitions
into being actually something that you
want to stay away from people like that
yeah really not the cool thing to do
anymore and doesn't even have to be
making fun of someone it could just be
like being obnoxious trying to see who
has the biggest person
led in the room yeah if you're out in
public doing this I mean I see kids
doing it all the time it's just annoying
to everyone else and I think that's
something that for most people starts to
fade away when you become an adult you
would hope to those who don't
they're just seen as really annoying
what about nap time like nap time is a
thing for little kids like baby leap all
the time whatever at a certain point
nap time becomes really lame but then it
becomes cool again when you're older
like we've now seen the productivity
benefits of napping throughout the day
and now I don't actually think that nap
time is stigmatized it seems like it's
an in-between thing like if you're in
seventh grade and you're like I got to
go home to my nap before soccer practice
or whatever there's big stigma with that
being very uncool but at a certain point
that one actually goes away yeah I was
dozing off there so I didn't remember
what you were saying but what about um
like when you're you know 12 years old
and you get like a new bicycle and
you're riding around with all your
friends and say your new BMX bike I mean
that's the coolest thing because you get
to use the roads just like as if you
were a car who had a car with a license
and everything else but then you get to
you know obviously people use bikes as
hobby or to commute but it's not seen as
the coolest thing to do maybe a
lateralized should do that actually I'm
totally fine with the urban biking I go
for bike ride totally I'm either with it
I just don't think it's considered cool
you know like riding a motorcycle or
like a fancy car oh you know I'm someone
who'll ride a bike around the city I
don't care yeah I don't agree with you
on this okay no I don't agree with you
on this one let's end on that one to see
what the view is now I'm not ending any
no I don't think it's a fence okay I
just think it's wrong and misguided but
we'll talk about it all fair pad yeah
okay those are some ideas send me your
thoughts great questions this week from
Brett Yuma and Dani we will talk to you
on the bonus show at david pakman.com
slash membership one week to go until
David Pakman show summer vacation just
giving you a heads up the show is not
going off the air after next week we
will just be on vacation I'll speak to
you on the bonus show